so we've already got the Labour Party
manifesto later on today we'll be
hearing what the conservative plans are
for the economy on Labour's policy as
well they have announcing today that
they will be helping to compensate
millions of women who missed out on
money because of the rise in the pension
age so that is the plan current plan put
forward by a tea shadow chancellor john
macdonald who joins us now in the studio
thank you very much for being with us
now I'm keen to get on to the details of
your at manifesto but I thought I'd just
start on brexit because jeremy corbyn's
said this week that if there was a
second referendum he would stay neutral
in that campaign would you stay neutral
who will members in the Shadow Cabinet
it will be able members of the
government at that time and will be able
to well campaign and I expect that as
well Wilson did individual members of
the party and Shadow Cabinet and cabinet
then will be able to campaign on the
basis of their judgement the party will
meet and discuss you know our proposals
which is negotiate a sensible deal put
that back to the British people
alongside remain and people will have to
make a judgement around that deal as
against remain and what about you well
do you see yourself staying neutral no I
won't and I don't think Jeremy's asking
people to do that how would you eat
where would you well I'll wait until I
see the details of the deal that we
negotiate I've set up and till now I've
always I was in the negotiations with
the Conservatives for six weeks and I
couldn't see a deal even emerging then
that could be remain but let's see what
we can negotiate whatever we do we've
got to get arrived at a situation where
the jobs in the economy are protected
and on that basis Germany's role as he
says will be the honest broker whatever
is then decided will then be implemented
by our Labour government you say you see
jeremy corbyn's role as being an honest
broker but some people looking at this
will be like this is the one issue that
everyone has got a view on everyone's
got an opinion on and jeremy corbyn if
he's Prime Minister will just duck out
is that really leadership no I think
this a different type of leadership that
we need at the moment we don't need a
leader that will divide the country it's
divided or
ready we need a leader who bill
consensus and I Jeremy's unique
character would enable that to happen as
I said that honest broker role this
needs are different points of view but
then saying look when we the people who
decide let the people decide then
whatever is designed by those people he
will honestly and fairly it and ensure
it's implemented we need a leader like
that at the moment to bring the country
back together again okay
and now let's move on to some policy you
generally because today you are
announcing compensation for women who've
been impacted by the rise in the state
pension age what your plans its redress
really these are the fifties women who
paid into their national insurance
expected to be retiring at sixty and
then legislation was introduced to
extend their retirement age and they
weren't properly informed and what was
they'd been to court
they've lost in the first stage of court
they're now appealing so I've had to
prepare a scheme as though the
government had actually lost we need
something that is in place to redress
this injustice and these are women who
have done everything asked of them
they're paid in they expect a retirement
age and then even in court the
government had to admit that within the
department working pensions they knew
that people hadn't been properly
informed the government's defense then
was that legislation doesn't have to be
fair or there's no responsibility or or
placed upon the government to notify
people individually that's not a good
enough it's expensive this though isn't
it
really expensive well it's expensive but
this is an entitlement this is not a
benefit estates are billion pounds over
a five year period as well but this is
this is a historic injustice we have to
address it some of these women have been
forced into penury and they were given
no adequate notice they were not
properly informed and it's caused real
hardship and some of these women if we
don't do it now
some of them will no longer be worse so
it's I think we have a we have a sense
of responsibility to address this
injustice I just want to focus a little
bit on the costings of this because you
really show manifested this week we can
have a little look at the costings
of this say what we're looking at here
as it's very detailed but effectively
all the sort of spending is on the left
and how you're going to pay for it is on
the right I can't find this policy in no
because this is we're tree
this is the way the government would
treat it as in the past if the
government loses in court it then has to
abide by the court decision we believe
we have to abide by this injustice
that's taken but hang on a minute sorry
I know you're 58 billion pounds and here
it is this is the scorecard of our
manifesto implementation when on these
decisions as they as well it's the same
of the government when they lost in
court on the bedroom tax and the lung
conditions as well it's outside of the
scorecard this is a very special
arrangement of contingency in the same
way government as in the past dealt with
matters like this this is at the scale
of this is injustice is enormous
this is a discrimination against women
in particular older women
it's many of them who are on low pay
anyway but now I think many of them have
suffered so it's an injustice we have to
address I'm not just debating whether
it's an injustice and I'm just working
out how it's gonna be paid Friday do you
think there's any there's no suggestion
then this is something that you've
decided or in the last few days after
Boris Johnson was giving me a hard time
whereas we've been working on this last
18 months we've met all with the
different groups the what we called the
waspey groups we consulted them on a
proposal a range of proposals including
this and we came to the conclusion that
if we didn't act soon this suffering and
stress would continue on but also as I
say some of these later that women are
older and may not be with us if we don't
act quickly it's not the only thing that
isn't in this costing document is it and
they mention the four-day week they
mentioned the four hundred billion pound
national transformation fund they
mentioned scrapping the state pension
age increase in rotation nationalization
well the greatest respect let's just go
through those shall we with regard to
the 32 hour week over a ten-year period
we've said we will set up a working time
Commission which will include employers
and trade unions and others they will
work out proposals and how we implement
over the 10 years it will only be
implemented by increases in productivity
within our economy largely resulting
from the investment that we're putting
in it's as simple as that
secondly with regard to our national
transformation fund it's referred to in
the in the grade book as we for this
grade
this is the detail costing I want to see
the Tori one by the way identically like
this but we'll see we'll find out the
other side you will see the national
transformation fund is separate from the
gradebook we make reference to it here
and is the capital program but of course
the costs of that all concerned here I
mean I just wondered and it like if
people feel that they just can't trust
some of the costs that you've let me
just go because you are expecting you
are spending an awful lot of money here
and you're also expecting to borrow a
lot of money here so I don't know how
much let me just go through it step by
step what this book does it sets out our
manifesto commitments costed and the
funding sources it also obviously
relates to the national transformation
from let me just take this which is the
poorest right so this is eighty three
billion pounds worth of revenue
expenditure that we're going to end
austerity and fund our public services
and address address some of the poverty
and hardship that people experience a
lot let me just finish on this we also
have a national transformation fun
contains two elements one is a green
transformation fund to tackle climate
change two hundred fifty billion pounds
over a ten-year program moving us from
fossil fuels on to alternative energy
sources wave solar wind power and
retrofitting people's homes so we
insulate people's of a customer the
second thing is a hundred and fifty
billion pound social transformation from
in over five years which will build us
the homes that we need build this invest
in our health service our schools and in
that way we're rebuilding our public
smoking
my next question is one of trust yeah
and because I just want to show you a
quick video of you speaking on Tuesday
this is what you had to say on Tuesday
earlier this week and over the weekend
there were reports that labor is playing
a windfall tax on oil companies and is
this true and if so please could you say
out how your proposal is worth okay John
okay I'm on the wheel for tax on oil
companies No
simple we are I believe the manifests
are already I mean on page 15 the
manifesto it says we will introduce a
windfall tax on all companies what I was
being asked there by the TV Telegraph
reporter is would I give the details of
the windfall test I wouldn't we just
heard the question you said no that's a
leak of manifesto if you listen to the
question itself he's asking me he said
will there be a winner nobody's asking
will you give us the details of it and I
said no what listen to me I said will
there be a winner we said will there be
a winner cause that'll will you give the
details of that matchup no I'm not going
to release the manifesto can you not see
many people listening to that will feel
that you've said one thing and in a
couple of days later if you listen
carefully enough that's exactly what you
asked me would I give the details I said
no it's a trust issue isn't it yes it is
and we've been that's why I published
this that's why it sets out in detail
where the funding will come from you've
also made a promise that no one who
earns less than 80,000 pounds will and
will pay more in taxes that a taxpayer
more for only on the richest what which
let's be clear what we've said there
will be no increase in the income tax
rates for those below eighteen thousand
pounds the top five percent will pay
more in income tax but our this than 95
percent will not pay though I have an
increase in their income tax rates or
the 80 or national chances but we have
to be honest with people don't we
because although there may not be any
increase in income tax people earning
less than this will see more increases
in other taxes won't they if there is a
Labour government you want to scrap the
most tax allowance for example that
would fall if you want to extend the
sugar tax that will impact everybody
effectively won't it so don't we need if
you want to transform the economy if you
want to make this spending if you want
to increase the state don't we just have
to be a bit more honest about what it
means it means all of us paying more and
well that's why I want just a wealthy
it's not just other people no that's
exactly why I've published this I've
said very very clearly what our income
tax proposals will be what will happen
on v80 say he'll admit then everyone
will end up they just go through what
we've done is we've show will be
absolutely explicit and straightforward
about where we will find the funding
that we need and where that funding will
go the can you can you admit don't you
admit that everybody not just the top 5%
will end
paying more taxes under a label well
what we're saying very clearly in terms
of income tax only top 5% have an
increase in the income just talking
about income well I'm just being
uncertain about what our rules are
ninety five percent of population
earners so ninety five percent of
earners will not have an increase in
their income tax rates or v80 or
national insurance where there will be
other elements of changes in taxation
rates we've laid them out here as well
and what we're trying to do is have a
fair taxation says and I've been very
explicit there you know the highest
earners will pay a bit more but also
we're reversing as well but we're
reversing some of the corporation tax
cuts we're introducing a financial
transaction tax on the city not a great
deal just to ask for the city but to pay
its way a bit more we bailed the banks
out ten years ago right and pay a bit
more back well we're also so we're going
to tackle tax evasion and tax avoidance
there'll be other elements yes that
we've set out here where there's been
tax giveaways and we're saying some of
those will be will be taken back to do
what to invest in our public services I
want to talk a bit about business
because on the show last Sunday I spoke
to Colonel Fairburn who is the boss of
the CBI one of the leading business
groups and this is what she said to me
she said we really understand the
questions that labor are asking but we
look at the policies on the table and we
have real concerns that they are going
to crack the foundations of our economy
do you I just wonder groups like these
business groups does it bother you that
they're scared at the thought of a
Labour government or do you think
actually that's just because they're
worried about change they're the enemy
it's a no then they're not the enemy at
all people do get worried about change
but I meet with Carolyn and the other
representatives of the business go
Jeremy Corbyn I meet with them I think
we're virtually monthly now in wish we
sought talk about our proposals and our
plans we listen to their views and take
some of their views into account of
course but the more important thing
we've said to them coming to government
with us and what I said to Carol in the
meeting before last that we had bring
forward your proposals about how you
want to come into a government with us
how you can help us shape policy but
more importantly how can you can deliver
them in that way over time you build
confidence you can they are bisque
feeling no no I don't think they are
because I've been to look you know
you've heard this before it sounds a
little bit like she said foundation she
representing some of her member
organizations who are going to pay a bit
more taxes of course that she's going to
have to represent some of their views
but when I meet with asset managers with
pension fund managers and business
leaders I talk them through our
investment plans I talked them through
about how we to decarbonize our economy
and they're up for this they are really
up for it are you happy to see
billionaires in the UK so say good are
you happy to see billionaires in the UK
I want to have a more equal society
billionaires exist but I would like much
more well I'd like a more equal society
if we could and I I think it's about
making sure that when we when we create
our new economy it's a stakeholder
economy where everyone has a share in it
and also where everyone gets the rewards
that they deserve but they're
distributed more fairly and I think I
meet with very rich people in the city
and elsewhere you know they don't want
to be stepping over homeless people when
they come out of their offices they want
they don't want to live in today knees
pay more well they are paying more under
our proposals a little bit more and they
don't want to live in gated communities
they want to live a society which is
safe so we have a proper police fondants
police service properly funded they want
to ensure that when they have emergency
treatment often that emergency treatment
for them mean that the wealthiest is
through an NHS hospital they want it
properly fill out well we've got you
know the big issue this election
campaign has been the prospect of
Scottish independence we're talking to
Nicola Sturgeon a bit later on the
program and I just want to ask you
quickly about Labor's position on
granting another second independence
referendum this is what your manifesto
says on it in the early years of a UK
Labour government we will not agree to a
section 30 order request request for
another referendum if it comes from the
Scottish come here what does early years
mean well those first few years whether
we're getting on the job be really
specific I wouldn't I wouldn't expect
anything in the first two or three years
because I've been you know the Scottish
people themselves are saying we've got
to concentrate on austerity and getting
that sorted we've got to concentrate on
sorting out brexit above all else we've
got an existential threat of climate
change that's a huge agenda and we see
the independence issue in terms of a
potential referendum it was a
distraction
from that so even if it's a red line for
the SNP that it would have to be in the
first two to three years that's not
something that you would give any no no
we wouldn't because we've after 20 out
of that look out there last year 700
people died on our streets homeless we
need to start building homes schools are
still having cuts class sizes increasing
infant mortality going up we've got that
we've got to address the priorities the
real real issues facing our community
that's what we'll do
just finally and it's clear that you
want to desperate to get in to number 11
and we'll find out in a few weeks if you
manage to do that if you don't you'll
have lost your second election in three
years is this is this your last chance
we're gonna win is it your last always
gonna win admire the optimism would you
put would you put money on it I've given
up on gambling just what I buy a lot of
my new year's resolutions but we're
gonna win okay Thomas don't oh thank you
very much